I watched him be on the sidelines for
the Orange Bowl where Florida beat
Virginia and then I heard him driving
around as he was helping call the Peach
Bowl where LSU destroyed Oklahoma for
ESPN Radio he's ESPN NFL draft analyst
and reporter Todd McKay how are you Todd
doing well I don't know if you were on
air or who was just in commercial but
you were talking about mispronouncing
some names yes I just want to let you
know t Higgins I called he's a wide
receiver for Clemson I called him T
Martin about 12 times hey man it happens
right I know I by the way I just kills
me that I can no no way I said t Martin
it was definitely T Higgins until they
had to play it back to me oh my are you
kidding I know and like you swear like
I've never I would never do that why
would I ever do that and you did you
know I mean your your colleague you know
tests with d-caf Metcalf and Here I am
calling Watson Winston Winston Watson
and then Winston is throwing a guy named
Watson - my head's exploding of course
there's no way I said it until I got at
least I'm sure your Twitter feed wasn't
a total dumpster fire like mine was Todd
oh wait a minute I'm sure there was
[Laughter]
again I'm you know having worked with
Mayock for as long as I did and then
Daniel Jeremiah for as long as I have I
know most of the time you are watching
top notch top rank if not number one
overall draft choices mostly on tape
you saw taro in person for ESPN Radio do
what he did at the Peach Bowl what in
the hell does it look like with your own
two eyes
Todd it was unbelievable it really was I
mean you know I was there for Vince
Young against USC just kind of taking
over the game and I've been fortunate
enough to see a lot of great
performances this one was different
don't this one it was watching a surgeon
go in and just have the best surgery
that you could possibly see and I know
he got protection and I know that his
receivers Justin Jefferson for for
starters making contested catches three
of them
for touchdowns I've never seen a
quarterback live more poised more
comfortable and more just in his own
skin and understanding exactly where he
needed to go with the ball and what he
was reading and more precise than he was
it was it was remarkable because so we
had him live last year and I thought he
was a pretty good player I thought he
was you know maybe a mid round pick and
then this year it's been completely
different studying all the tape and then
watching him lives it it was a watching
the game actually slowed down he made
the game slow down for me which is hard
to say you know I've watched enough
paper it's pretty slow for me he made
the game slow down for me because of how
comfortable he was in the pocket and how
informed he was about what he was
reading it was it really was a special
performance watching him against
Oklahoma and I get it Oklahoma is not a
great defense they've had struggles all
year long but it doesn't I mean even
seven on seven to watch someone that
precise and that in control really
impressive well I mean look we could we
could sit here and parse anything
especially the Oklahoma defense but the
throws he was making Todd he's thrown
back shoulder ease high pointing to the
right high point guys he's leading the
right guys he's also keeping his head up
as he's leaving the pocket I mean he it
really was amazing so that said yes
whack on a I think it was a second down
and let's call it a second and eight I
forget what it was he got absolutely
buried pops right up and then the next
the next throw is from inside the pocket
I'm in the end zone watching him
he's throwing towards me it's an in
cutting route about 15 yards he took the
sack on the play before so now it's
third and 13 third and 15 something
along those lines he's gonna he's
getting ready to get hit again and he
doesn't flinch he stares it down and he
throws the ball with anticipation to a
spot I and I think it's gonna be an
interception from the endzone that I'm
looking at and all of a sudden the
receiver comes darting into the middle
and then cutting route and boom first
down to have the
you know the gun hang in the pocket
after taking that hit you don't see a
lot of college quarterbacks do that
usually the eyes go down they start
running around and either make a mistake
or just take the fact and punt and move
on key hung in there and threw for a
first down and that's kind of the
difference between him and most college
quarterbacks that I watched and evaluate
Todd McShea here on the Rich Eisen show
from the world wide leader so you know
as well as I do whether it's going to be
somebody who's hoping he doesn't go
number one overall so he drops or the
over parsing the overhand ringing that
usually does happen because the town of
evaluation portion of our calendar is
way too long what's going to be what's
gonna be in the knock what's gonna be
the knock we hear around march/april is
it gonna be like in the world okay what
what about the idea of like where did he
come from what why you know to go from
one year to this could it be a flash in
the pan we're gonna hear that sort of
stuff to Joe Brady with and doesn't have
the right coaching maybe he's going to
be the guy that we saw a year ago but
they didn't let him play last year
though that was the difference they LSU
did what LS she was done for the past
two decades last year and ran the
football and didn't know what they
wanted to be offensively he had just
arrived from Ohio State after three
years and and was developing into a
leader and trying to figure out how to
beat that guy and you could I mean you
could tell in the first quarter of the
first game this year he's just a
different tack he came in with
confidence he knew who he wanted to be
and Joe Brady brought out the best in
him and yes like Clyde Edwards Alera was
was a huge help at the running back
position but he didn't play the other
night the wide receivers grew up a
little bit all those young receivers
grew up and they played better but it
really to me was him developing and
figuring out who he is and what he wants
to be and being in an offensive system
that was more like what he played in
high school
and more like the one that he had
learned for a few years at Ohio State
and then he took kind of a year
sabbatical to become a leader and become
the guy and then and then Joe Brady came
in and sure
burr go into burrow and I I was it took
me a while it was four or five games
into the year where I finally gave in
but he's the best quarterback that's
eligible in this year's class we'll see
what to Otunga Velo is gonna announce on
Monday I'm hearing both sides but I
think there's a much better chance of
him going back to school than I ever
would have thought but regardless I
think Joe Burrell is gonna be the number
one overall pick and he's going to be
the first quarterback taken by Todd
let's jump into it I mean what possible
reason would to have to go back I have
no idea I've no idea
Brooke I really don't I write because
you must be hearing evaluators I
wouldn't take another snap in college if
I was doing and I would advise his
family in that I've talked to Nick Saban
about it you have and Nick stop pushing
him Nick is you know if Nick is as good
as anyone in the in the game as sure
giving the players the information and
letting them decide and he wants to make
sure that they get the right information
I will again as much as any coach in the
profession and he told me he talked to
20 teams and we were talking about all
of their different players you know
there's 15 players from that team who
could wind up being drafted or lined up
leaving early and he wanted to make sure
that every single player had the right
information to it it just comes down to
what he thinks medically what his
doctors are telling him medically right
what he's getting in terms of an
evaluation back and and that is the part
that none of us know right now that's
the bit it's one of the biggest unknowns
I can think of in terms of a potential
top five pick if you're just evaluating
him from a talent standpoint we just
don't know when old buddy knows except
his inner circle and we'll just we'll
find out a lot of things I think on
Monday well I mean in the way it's gonna
work
Todd McShea here on the Rich Eisen show
as you and I know and let's let's inform
our our list of listeners and viewers of
this conversation his medical will be
the most maybe the most viewed item at
the combine this year of any even
correct
anybody's 40-yard dash or weight and
wraps or name address will be if if he
is if he decides to declare for this
draft right it will be the most
scrutinized aspect yes any part of the
entire pre-draft process and no question
about and it's and then they'll do the
read the medical recheck and you know
the first week in April usually and then
every single team that has a chance to
draft them or has any interest in
drafting and will send their medical
team out and then they'll bring him in
to their facility and go through more
medical checks it will be a very very
long process for four to a tongue about
Lola if he decides to declare for the
strap and even if it's a year from now
but it will be as scrutinized as I can
remember any individual in the whole
process because the tape doesn't lie and
then when he goes on the grease board
and when he sits face to face with an
owner or a coach he's gonna absolutely
knock it out of the park meaning they're
all gonna be like one of the best guys
you've ever been around right which
means there's nothing to dislike about
him his competitiveness even always been
injured he's been he's tough his
teammates love him his coaches love him
there's not a single person who's ever
said one negative thing about to or that
I've ever talked to and I've been I've
been digging I've been trying he's
amazing it's just the medical I know
they're all gonna go to the doctors and
basically say tell me something good
please tell me something good for him so
he's just got a figure do I want to go
under the NFL that way if this weekend
he's he and his doctors are looking at
whatever medical report they're getting
and they're like you can do this I mean
that's essentially the choice he has
here here's the other thing that I that
I've been told from a very good source
okay he can't do anything until April
like you there's nothing he can do
physically and don't April so the Monday
comes and passes and he has no idea he
just doesn't know the doctors don't
definitively know because it's just a
waiting it's a
process and they're hopeful and
everyone's saying the right thing but
that that would be the only reason to go
back is because you just don't know
because in in April right before the
draft is when they think you'll be able
to start you know walking and start to
do some physical activity and to not
know that information and all of a
sudden bang that you know the
twenty-first year that's that's a lot to
to wait for so but then do you go back
to school and play again and risk injury
I it's a really difficult decision for
him it really is I don't I don't know
what I would do if I was if I was his
parents trying to advise him I would say
don't play another college snap but I'm
also not saying the best idea is to be
in this draft and then two weeks before
the draft the doctors come out and say
well it's going to be another eight
months before you're able to start doing
physical activity you're playing
football again and that's not going to
help so I it's brutal
Todd McShea here on the Rich Eisen show
who else has helped himself in the bowl
season Todd Oh in the bowl season I
would say Jeff Okuda the quarterback for
Ohio State he had a heck of a game
played really well everyone for for
Ellen who plays really well and helped
it had a great game you know the safety
he's gonna be a top ten pick did nobody
tell Joey Jude did nobody tell Jerry
Judy how highly he was gonna be drafted
and tell him to sit out the verbose it
was but nobody did nobody but in his ear
Todd come on come on I mean I love it
dad I'm saying don't play but I love the
fact that he played and every evaluator
loves the fact that he played he had
nothing that he had to show or play for
he's a top ten pick he and CDM are two
receivers that really had not very my
least CD was playing in a in a
semi-final game for Oklahoma right so it
was understandable and everyone expected
him to play Jerry duty only out there
and playing against Michigan I thought
it was awesome I love that could this be
a good this could this be an AJ Green
Julio Jones situation with the two of
them yeah absolutely I think those are
the top two guys
Higgins who I call T Martin is coming
out of Clemson but um but I think Judy's
in 20 years of evaluating wide receivers
evaluating players he's the best route
runner I've ever evaluated Wow
yeah what a draft not the biggest he's
not the fastest he's gonna run a four or
five and it's all good
he's just like Marvin Harris he just
knows how to get open he knows how to
get open and CD is great after the catch
and is tough and physical and does all
the little things but those two guys are
in my opinion both were top 10 picks all
right last couple questions for your
child you hearing anything about Lincoln
Riley maybe going to cowboys anything at
all on that front I haven't heard
anything I haven't heard I've heard some
other names
I mean I've I've heard his name I didn't
talk to him about it he he was asked the
question and he couldn't have run away
from the question fast enough obviously
he did not specifically say that he was
not taking a job or would not be
interested in the job he just ran away
from the question all right and then
last thing for you I give you three I
put you to desk I give you a sharpie
I'll give you a pencil and then a pen in
an old jar or a container of whiteout
which kids might not know but I give you
I give you those three items
what are you used to write down Jo
burrow and chase young one two in the
draft what do you do
sharpie Sharpie now do you didn't even
stutter that's gonna happen Oh borrow
bangles chase young Redskins that's the
way it's gonna go
yep then you can play this back just
like someone's gonna play back the tee
Martin my Winston Watson stuff sure got
it Todd I loved uh everything you did
loved hearing your own on the call my
son and I watched the Orange Bowl was
great good times
happy new to you of course happy New
Year to you and yours let's chat often
please right back at ya but you got
right back atcha that's Todd McShea at
McShea 13 for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on
live or download the Rich Eisen show app